All right.
The next presentation is
with Pablo Fernandez Macchia. So welcome
back, Pablo. Hello here.
Okay, I did take us on an adventure of
curiosity. Yes. I'm going
to start sharing my screen. Let me know
if everything is all right.
Should be perfect.
Yes. Cool.
So this is one of my favorite memes and
probably most of you know it.
This reference is
the cave of Platon and
to me it was kind of fine treated truth
that now with active inference
seems like we are closer to demonstrate.
That how it is.
So the first time
that I start act and
surf at the Institute,
this was kind of my feeling or my
face was looking into something
that it was complex,
scary and look
interesting. So I went
why I decided to go through it.
I envision a world where people is
driving by stronger incentives that
motivate them to reduce uncertainty in
the systems they are part of.
My approach is through games which are
going to go later. But I really on this
talk, want to encourage all kinds
of persons or people that are
curious. And I want them to act
and get involved in the community.
Because you may find that for now most
of the actors are
scientists and very well on reputed
people. And you might think that you are
not a part of it,
but very far away from that.
The Institute. Encourage the opposite.
So I'm super glad to have
been through this journey and I wanted
to share a little bit of my background
and then we go to the game.
Here is the second and last meme. The
world you were raised to survive is no
longer exist. We are on digital
revolution and with this digital
revolution it comes a bunch of different
things that are evolving and hopefully
bring us to a better world. Okay,
who I am? I'm Pablo. My name is Pablo.
But more defined or what
best define me is my action and my
experiences.
I think role gameplays and sports
movies are super important and as a kid
I was dyslexic
and the system didn't fill my
necessities. So I really hated school.
But I love learning and it's something
that I've been doing all my life. And
it's curious how a system that is
designed to give you knowledge and to
help you with the learning, in my case
it didn't work at all.
That's a little starting point.
I believe in the copy transformation and
combine of things and on my adulthood
everything shifted and I became
successful, professional and
I love it.
Teams. What I do for a
living is product manager and
what I do on my pet projects site
projects, call it as you want is related
to gaming and gamifying
organizations and experiences.
Nowadays I trust more my intuition which
is something that it really was broken
during my childhood and you will see a
little bit more about that. Here are
some things of my interest.
Licenses like open science which
is the case of the Institute philosophy
that's the first meme education,
governance, family, art,
love, communication, technology and
nature and a bunch of other things that
I will be happy to share any other time.
One of the questions that Daniel asked
me for this talk is what was exciting
for me about all this,
what right? And for me,
when I give talks, I like to share a
view of the last hundred years and
the Industrial revolution and how the
ones that were on this world before us
did something right. I'm sure that we
all know big mistakes or
big things that have failed or
that could be better through
iterations. But on data
it's very promising and
very good. I think it's inspiring
to have the basic education,
how it grows, the vaccination, what it
did for us, democracy and
how poverty dropped draxily,
how literacy it grew and
because all these things, child
mortality just went very
low. So basically
the future of education is what makes
me be excited.
How I ended up on this ecosystem.
It's super random and I'm going to
explain it in hopefully two to
five minutes. I as a product manager
and very interested on technology.
I heard about Blockchains back in
2015 and I didn't understood anything at
all. And then back in 2017
I heard about a I didn't start them,
did not play that game. But it was
raising a fun thing to consider,
which is digital assets and ownership of
those digital assets.
For now, we didn't have a technology
that could scale and that was good
enough to ensure that the digital assets
that you own were you yours and you
had the freedom of transaction on them.
I did understand that very fast and
because I'm a game player and as a game
player you always have your different
assets and do things with them. And as
well, I have been collecting music
and all kind of digital
assets. I bought this very
famous collection of punks and
sold them very fast before I could be a
millionaire. But due to in 2021
I decided that I wanted to build
something. And then back then I went
through this beautiful project that was
the first art saw on Ethereum, which one
of the artists it was Daniel Friedman.
So I, as a curious person and
person that has been working with
artists, I always like to know what is
the driver of those artists, what they
do, and try to get in
their walls, to understand better and
to get as much information as I can
before I decide to encourage
or collect or just
always deeper on music or
art. For me, is very nice
thing to do. So I discovered these cards
and education was
one of them. And I went through Flickr
which is where it was the first at least
that I found place where it was.
And the license. It was Creative Commons
license of not commercial use but it
was an open license which I been part
of Creative Commons community for a very
long time since I was working with
musicians and I think it's one of the
best things that happened to the
internet. These are
some of the pragmatic things that the
audience cares about. Hopefully we will
have some of these on our games.
AI for sure is going to be there.
Free energy principle is going to be one
of the things that hopefully we help
to minimize and to make
it funnier. Games or happier games and
games that help organizations to be
better. The human factor,
it's super important for me. And
implementation and action I learned by
doing and it's one of the values that
the Institute encouraged more. So I just
jump on things and try to understand
them through doing and sharing as
I'm doing now. Here are the
epistemics and collective
is one of them that I'm as well.
Super interest agents,
of course,
practical and curiosity which is the
adventure that I have the feeling that
I'm being involved all my life and that
I encourage always my two
girls to be curious and to open
things and look behind the doors and
just be an active. Here are some values
that I like to point which are
exploration, the culture of curiosity
that I did mention a lot.
Continuous learning because that
experience on the school. I think I
just keep going and keep going and it's
something that sometimes bad experiences
could turn out in good habits.
Learning by doing, as I already told.
Integrity and inclusivity. Honesty,
accountability, a big one. Trying to be
professional on everything that you do.
For me, I started as human being.
Curious people
of all backgrounds and perspectives are
welcome to the Institute.
I would be very happy to be the link and
to speak with someone
that has doubts or if I couldn't help.
I think I could help on the very early
stage. If you're not very technical
person, I think I could help. There we
are learning by doing. I would love to
everyone that's on the stream,
I'm going to share this link which is a
new game that we are testing and I'm
excited to share it with you.
It's the adventure of Curiosity and here
Daniel. I'm going to copy and paste
the link. It would be awesome.
Okay. There's a tiny typo on your
slides. It just ends with a curiosity.
Thank you. But I'm going to paste it
into the YouTube live chat.
Okay, thank you. Yeah, I told you I'm
a Dyslexic. I have all kind of titles
throughout my life. Sorry for that. I
always try to improve share
the. Yeah, I put it in the YouTube chat
so people can head over there. All
right, yeah. Could you tell us about
this platform? And this is the first
active game?
Yes, we started
thinking on how to do game a
while ago and we decided to go
with this picture
that explains how it works. Actually
it's simple and you have four
pieces, the internal state, external
state, and in the middle you have
the sensory state and the active state.
So here is the mission.
You have some instructions that you can
read and would be fun if you go
through them and you can go either
way. And here we are going to go through
the sensory state where you're going to
listen to a music where
some notes you can censor
that are not in the famous song
for Elise.
So you have to take
notes and
you can go and you can see that we are
on the Markov blanket which saw
everything very delineate as Dali
would paint it. And here is your
active part of the game where
you have to do something which is add
the different notes that your
professor, music professor is telling
you don't miss because you probably on
the external
state are trying to play
the music. So you have to infer
that you are missing some notes and
go to the
active state and start walking
through the right node. If I
miss the node, I just follow into
the nothing and come back into my
internal state. So probably
would have to go back and sensor again.
And once I take the right actions
and the right nodes, I can go and
solve the puzzle. And the
idea here is to have a tool,
gaming tool to explain
so you can experience how this
active inference on free energy works.
And once you go
to the end of that adventure,
which I'm not going to finish because
it's something that players should do,
you're going to have a door where you
have to put the sequence in low
case of
what were the missing notes. And it's
going to allow you to come inside the
treasure room where you
will have feedback,
feedback that you can send us and we
will be very happy to have it. And then
if you have a wallet,
you will be able to have digital asset.
If not, we will add information to
help people to go from web two
to web three and to get those digital
assets. And here
to be developed would be future
adventures that I would be very happy to
do. So this
was pretty much the presentation and
hopefully we have new players
in the coming days. Hope you have
fun. And I really encourage
anyone to discover and
play with all these ideas and
thoughts and experiments and feelings
that I have the gut feeling that are
going to revolutionize how we understand
the world and how we can
improve in it by reducing uncertainty.
So thank you and I
don't know, Daniel, if you have any
comments or something in this last ten
minutes. Oh, yeah, we can definitely
talk for a few minutes. I'm seeing many
fun comments and questions in the chat
so people can post it. Yeah, the
gameplay is smoother on even a normal
computer. It may look choppy on the live
stream, but it's quite a nice playing
experience. Maybe just a little context
like how did you get into building these
worlds or what kind of tools are these?
And we obviously don't see them in
today's mainstream educational and
research offerings. But what could that
even be to bring together this kind of
immersion and role playing
with education research?
Yes, I we
playing role games and role games you
have very diverse kind
of players. So I was playing with
guys like me,
had a struggle through the school and
guys that end up being researchers
like yourself because they were very
good in those environments.
For me, it was like we are sharing a lot
of cognitive values
and information and they are really
having fun with me. So what
the academia is telling me is not
what I'm feeling outside
academia. So that through
the years it became more and
more clear that was one of the drivers
to have a very diverse kind of friends
and that one of the most important
things for me to learn. It was having
fun and to be a good
professional, I have to be enjoying what
I'm doing and to enjoy what I do, it has
to have that gamify feeling of it.
In 2021, I just went
straight to explore that road because
Blockchains, what can do is have a
persistent sea of objects and
attributions to those objects and to
those wallets that you can add and build
on top of them. It's like having a huge
database for a game purpose and
then you figure out that a game is kind
of our organization. So you need
rules, you need to share values, you
need to have what we
are building now, which is the cecian
cedo which you agree with the players,
what's going to be about and how it's
going to work. And we are building
this fantastic storytelling
of how kind of
world where it was in the early
20s compared to what's happening now
in this imaginary world that's
complementary to what's happening in
real life. And we are just exploring
those areas for three years. And once
I got into the
Institute, we started serving these
ideas. You send us to do
a system thinking course that it was
super cool.
We explore and learn and this document
that I can share, it was very important
for us to understand and we find
out the necessity to be able to compute
what we are doing. So we start focusing
more on ontology on all
the bricks that you need to
understand to build the
skeleton of something that could last
for decades, which is
the idea. And we are trying to build it
so everyone can copy, paste,
fork it and do whatever they want with
the game, adapt it to their own
organizations and use it on
their favor. And we are just exploring
and having fun.
That's awesome. And there's so
many pieces there. It's true about the
fun and the curiosity, those intrinsic
motivations like being 6 hours deep into
counting ants in the desert or 5000
pipette pushes deep or whatever it
is in the trenches and in the last mile.
And it
can be easy to lose sight. But when
we lose sight and when we put out the
fire and the spark, it's a cold,
dark night, and no
career or status or extrinsic
valuation is going to provide simply
the joy and the deeper meaning
of to two people going on
a little adventure running around this
space, being inside active inference
rather than active inference. Being like
this high speed train that's leaving
anyone behind or you're on the outside
and it's taking these twists and turns
and you're getting thrown off. It's like
it is cool and air conditioned in this
space and people
play and watch a lot of games where they
wield violent arms and not
even like saying whether that's good or
bad. It's just it is a genre to want to
have a camera either in a character's
head first person perspective or a
camera in a second or a third person
perspective, which you can switch
between here and those kinds. Of topics
about egocentric versus allocentric
navigation and our ability to have a
perspective swap on ourself and be
able to take that kind of like out of
body situational awareness in
real spatial settings and just to be
able to cruise through this space and
it's like, yeah, there's no right way to
boomerang. You could go from external to
sensory. You could go here or there.
It's an appetizer and a
fertilization that we've really just
never seen.
Okay, yeah. Thank you very much,
Daniel, for this.
Any last thoughts or comments? No,
just enjoy while we are here, which is,
I think, our mission.
All right. Thank you, Pablo. I'm sure
everyone's going to really enjoy this
and let's also, of course, continue to
develop these games and continue to
offer these on ramps and have times
where we're meeting up in these spaces
and playing around. Thank you.
All right, bye. Farewell.
All right.